تقريبا بعد يوم كامل على العمليه الواسعه
التي ادفت بها القوات الامريكيه والقوات
البريطانيه اهدافا
داخل اليمن في الحديده وبعض المناطق
الاخرى ونحن ننقل ايضا هذا الخبر العاجل
عن عن اسوشيتد بريس عن مسؤولين الامريكيين
بان الموقع الذي استهدفته الضربه
الامريكيه الجديده في اليمن كان يشكل
تهديدا وهناك حديث بانه كان مبنى للرادار
يستخدمه الحوثيون في عملياتهم في البحر
الاحمر الى اين تتجه الامور
برايك ان الولايات المتحده
تحاول التخفيف من حده التصعيد لكن في نفس
الوقت التقلي من الاضرار التي يلحقها
الحوثيون وايضا التقليل من التهديد الذي
يهدد الملاحه البحريه لكي لا تضطر لتغيير
المسار الى راس الرجاء الصالح هم اعتقدوا
ان يوم امس حققوا الكثير لكن على ما يبدو
لم يحققوا كل شيء وهم الان يحاولون اتمام
العمليه وفي نفس الوقت تفادي الحاق الاذى
بالمدنيين على طريقه لا يقوم بها
الاسرائيليين حتى الان ما يقوم به
الحوثيون اثر على الملاحه فيما يختص ب 80
بلدا على الاقل ما ادى الى تؤثر
المستهلكين في شتى انحاء العالم واشنطن
تسعى لاقناع الحوثين بان يتوقفوا من تلقاء
انفسهم هذه هجمات ولكن ربما الضربات ستوقف
مؤقتا فقط الجانب الامريكيه تحدث
عن ضمان سلامه الملاحه في البحر الاحمر
والسؤال هنا السؤال ببساطه بهذه العمليات
هل بالفعل تكون المنطقه امنه لعبور هذه
السفن هل ستتخذ الشركات القرار بالعوده
مجددا خلال هذه الايام التي تشهد هذا
التصعيد وان كان حتى هذه اللحظه محدودا في
بعض
العمليات
هذا امر يجب ان ننتظر لنرى ما يحدث بشانه
لكنني اخمن انه لن يكون له تاثير لان
الكثير من القرارات اتخذت على اساس كلفه
بوليصه التامين وفي حالات الحرب طبعا كلف
التامين تزداد والشحنات تغير مسارها لتذهب
حوالي افريقيا لكن ما لم حتى الان طبعا
الحوثيين تجنبوا
مهاجمه المنشات النفطيه لاسباب مختلفه
ربما منها نصيحه من الايرانيين لكن هذا
العمل سيؤثر فقط وبشكل مؤقت ما يقوم به
الحوثيون ازاء الحرب في غزه لكن طالما
تبقى طرق الملاحه خط
على الشركات شركات الشحن البحري ان تلجا
الى الطرق الاكثر طولا واذا ما قاموا
باللوك طريق البحر الاحمر هذا ما سيعرض
السفن والبحار على متنها للكثير من الخطر